consider these two unlike fractions 2x3
and
3x5 say we want to find out which one is
greater the best way to compare two
unlike fractions is by making their
denominator same the question is what do
we choose as the common
denominator well we take the LCM of the
two denominators as a common
denominator the denominator are three
and five hence we need to find the LCM
of three and five since three and five
have no common factors the LCM will be
their product 3 * 5 =
15 we have to make the denominator of
each of these fractions equal to 15 look
at the first fraction we write 2x3 as
something over 15 we just have to find
this something to get 15 in the
denominator we multiply the denominator
by five and to keep the ratio unchanged
we also multiply the numerator by five 2
* 5 gives us 10 the ratio is hence
written as 10x
15 similarly the second ratio also has
to be written with 15 as a denominator
3x 5 equal something over 15 we have
have to multiply 5 with three to get 15
hence we also multiply three with three
to get 9 by 15 as our second
ratio now we have the same denominator
in each case these two fractions are
actually like fractions remember we
haven't changed the value of any of the
fractions we have just written it
differently and to compare like
fractions we just compare the
numerators since 10 is greater than 9 we
can say that 10x 15 is greater than 9 by
15 10x 15 is
2x3 and 9x 15 is 3x 5 hence the first
ratio is greater than the second one
remember when the fractions are unlike
make the denominators
[Music]
same